- You see this world in New York City,
and it just seems like Shangri-La.
It sparkles and glows, and it's just full
of this endless potential.
But also, you know, oh hi!
Whatcha doing?
I'm Desi Delong, I'm a
metalsmith in New York City,
and this is my studio.
Metalsmithing became a passion for me
the second I struck hammer to anvil.
It's extremely important
for me to have a vehicle
in this city.
It's a Subaru Impreza.
I use it to pick up equipment.
I drive every morning to my studio.
I also use it to travel
to and from my shows
up and down the east coast
that are 10 to 12 hour drives.
This car is just along for the ride,
and I've been on a pretty
crazy ride the past six years.
The life I had before moving to New York,
I had a full-time job at Duke University
as a nurse in the ICU.
I had a beautiful little crossman home.
I had found that I was
completely apathetic,
just passionless, and I wanted a change,
and I wanted something that felt foreign.
I wanted to be uncomfortable.
I wanted a challenge.
I realized I had to get
back to my first love
which is making.
I didn't even really
think about how difficult,
challenging, expensive,
or hard it was going to be
to learn metalsmithing and
make a living doing it.
All I thought about was just, do it.
I chose to move to New York City
because I wanted to see what
living in a city would do
to my work.
I love driving to
galleries that have my work
so that I can see how
they put it on display.
What I have in common
with Subaru is creating
a quality product that you can rely on
that's going to work and it's
going to serve its purpose.
I don't wanna put
anything out in the world
unless I'm absolutely passionate about it.
My past experience as a nurse is intimacy
with body and form really
influences the pieces that I make,
because I think about these pieces
and how are they going
to drape on the body.
My knowledge of anatomy and physicality,
that's what really influences the designs.
I've had a life that's
practical and stable and safe,
and now I've had a life
that's unstable and risky.
After experiencing both versions of life,
I can't really do anything now
unless I'm absolutely completely engaged.